[Music]
I'm really excited I think a timing is
perfect book is going to really help a
lot of people
[Applause]
[Music]
first things first there's this crazy
storm that's just starting now and I
have some work out I got to go to the
pool and get my work out John
here it is and I'm hoping the pool is
open hasn't started to look pretty nasty
out there
Oh
[Music]
I wonder if anyone's going to be at the
pool weird talk goin come to the pool
when it's raining out
just getting it wet anyway alright let's
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
boom 4,000 and cool done time to get
home okay 4,000 yards today actually
felt pretty good
I started getting back into the pool
with some focus and some intention back
around mid-november and it sort of felt
like a wet noodle for the last couple
months and today was kind of a
breakthrough everything kind of clicked
in and I could actually feel my stroke
again I started to feel like myself
which is really nice
because the 50 I'm starting to wonder
it's going to come back but feeling good
and fun to swim in the rain and now
going back home we got a lot going on at
home today busy
so what setups have you done they did
portrait of me in front of the wall and
they did purchasing planes to tears and
beautiful so we can do a quick one with
you right here and then I think Danny
Imam one of you running up the stairs so
what do you love about this new book the
gee-gees is not I think it's it's going
to be an absolute game changer you know
there are so many people who are
interested in the plant-based lifestyle
who like the idea of going vegan but
then they'll say oh I would do it but
you know cheese like I just can't give
up cheese and for whatever reason cheese
has a strong grip the strong hold on
people and so the idea behind the book
really is to free people from that and
implements of that dairy clutch I
suppose and Julie has spent the better
part of the last year and a half two
years turning our kitchen into this
laboratory to you know crack the
equation wide open on how to prepare
plant these cheeses that are actually
actually taste good and are not hard to
make I'm her number one taste tester so
I know think of the quality of what
these changes are and it's unbelievable
I think it's going to blow people's
minds and then to be able to teach them
how to do it at home it's like okay
you know when you taste these everything
from breda camembert to you know these
Goudas and goat cheeses some of them are
just completely indistinguishable from
their dairy versions and you can't help
but think like how is it possible that
you can make these without dairy so I'm
really excited I think its timing is
perfect book is going to really help a
lot of people tell me a little bit about
her influence in changing your lifestyle
to plant base she would be in flow
actually and it really began with her
journey to healing herself from cursive
even though you know at the time I was
stuffing my face with cheeseburgers and
you know essentially eating a I called
the window diet like if you roll down
your window in your car and they hand
you food that's what you needed for the
junk food junkie junk food addict for a
long time and I was at that time too but
I was able to kind of observe her
navigate that whole process and come out
the other side yeah I know it's the
first time that I'd actually he'd
somebody really healed himself with food
so even though I didn't change my habits
right away that seed was planted and so
when I had my moment on the staircase
when I was finally ready to kind of
reckon with that myself you know she was
my resource like I didn't go out and
read a bunch of books or watch a bunch
of documentaries I just turned to Julie
and I said now you know it's time for me
to do this will you help me so I think
that that sort of existential malaise
that I was weather and manifested in a
lot of these unhealthy lifestyle habits
like I began to medicate my emotional
state through food and lifestyle choices
so the fast food was that you know the
south to the emotional distress that I
was experiencing because I could no
longer use to
and alcohol right so I replace that
welcome to sunny Los Angeles X dropping
in you guys thought I would bring you a
little day in the light here nothing
special just a typical kind of
walkthrough of what a typical day looks
like for me
what's up Facebook spend a minute I
think I missed like the last two weeks
of doing a facebook live so sorry about
that
I'll give people a couple minutes to
tune in here and and dial it up but it's
nice to be back with you I had a little
bit of free time today so I thought it'd
make a good opportunity to kind of
impromptu jump in Carrie wants to know
Carrie Gaylord wants to know can you
articulate your goals for a pillow yeah
sure so a pillow is this race that I'm
training for it's in early September in
Sweden it is a swim run multi-sport
World Championship of that over the
course of one day you end up swimming
about 10 kilometres and running about 40
miles but there are 50 q transitions so
you're swimming in these few words and
then you're climbing up on rocks and
running across these little islands and
jumping back in the water and swimming
again it's a pretty cool event it's more
like an adventure race it's way outside
my comfort zone it's unlike anything
I've ever done before so I'm excited to
tackle it and my goals for it are just
to you know listen at age 50 I would
love to be competitive I would love to
be you know in the in the top pack but
more importantly than that I want to
have a good time you know I want to be
as fit as possible I want to be as
physically mentally and emotionally
prepared as possible as I can for this
event and then I want to go and enjoy
myself I want to do it for the jewel
so I don't have any super hardcore core
goals around it other than walking away
from it and feeling like I gave it my
all and I learned something about myself
and I judge myself in the process so
when Beverly Hills was going to this
really fancy hotel I'm going to meet
this guy Alexander mark we reached out
to me I don't know him the French
entrepreneur and philanthropist who
podcast man it's doing some really
interesting things in the charity world
so let's see what it's all about at
least with gear two divisions Olivia
don't only do it yet so you can keep
your artistic losses on I've never done
he our ego off her death yeah four full
years right for the first time you won't
know we always members return right now
so you would remember this
video remember this museum governor or
so as we saw in this in Mumbai in this
swamp into Ravi where a million people
believe the average life expectancy
there is 39 years old so now you want to
holler India
that was a cool meeting I think that guy
is doing some really interesting things
have you can make a potentially a great
hot cash cow so I'm going to think about
that and definitely follow up with him
in the meantime
epic foundation I'll put a link to epic
foundation down in the show notes check
it out he showed us some really cool
stuff and it's hearts in the right place
and I think it's really cool what he's
building so it was great to meet him I'm
really stoked that he reached out to me
all right that's it I think this is
where I'm going to call it for today's
vlog thanks for tuning in you guys and I
think I'll just leave you with this for
those of you who have followed me over
the last couple years you know that I
made a concerted effort to try to be a
little bit of a blogger on this platform
last year and then the consistency with
which I was uploading precipitously fell
off a cliff and then I disappeared from
YouTube well I'm back as you can tell
from this video there was somebody else
holding the camera in certain parts
throughout this video that's Michael
Gray I brought him on board to be my
collaborator partner on video so that I
hopefully can create a sustainable way
to continue to produce helpful video
content for you guys and be on a
schedule we're on uploading with a lot
more regularity and consistency I've got
a lot of ideas and plans and things that
I want to do on this platform including
starting to video some of my podcasts
we're building out a studio space for
that purpose doing a little bit more
vlogging and subject matter specific
videos so leave a comment below let me
know what kind of content you would like
me to be sharing here I want to make
this work for you and I want to have
these videos be of maximum benefit for
you guys and what you're looking for
from me so that's it
no promises not consistency with these
vlogs but it was fun to get myself back
in to this medium into this platform
it's not the greatest vlog of all time
but at least I'm saying
hey I'm still here how you guys doing
and I'll see you guys back here soon
until then make it
[Music]